my name is Ray Roman I'm a filmmaker I
began in 2000 most recently I've been
working on documentaries the past couple
years I'm currently working on a project
concussed the American dream directed by
David Kino
were both producers on the film and I
had to really go back and see which
video it was from thumb courts that
inspired me the most and I had 57 film
courts videos favorited so it's a little
bit tough to say okay this one I think
inspired me the most but I chose the
interview of Kevin Gant I believe it was
titled Kevin Gant talks about nothing
except what he has as an artist and the
reason why this video inspired me is
because at the time in 2012 when I saw
it I was a little bit lost in which
direction I was going as a filmmaker and
I was working on a documentary at the
time and it was just one of the biggest
projects that I've been working on
there's so many hours of footage I was
just kind of overwhelmed and it was this
video that helped inspire me because you
know within the video Karen asked Kevin
you know what kind of affirmations do
you do or things do you do to manifest
things to happen in your life and he was
just realizing within the video you know
he was saying you know the time is now
to embrace yourself as an artist of
which you can do as a art as a creator
for me as a filmmaker so it was just one
of those videos that kept coming back to
and watching over the years and here we
are and years later and I'm working on
my biggest project to date so I'm just
really thankful for film courage they've
always been that resource where you
could actually go to and you know learn
you know ways to promote a film or sell
a film or you know how to put a crew
together so I'm just thankful for film
courage and look forward to seeing some
more
you